today Hard Rock International presented
its early renderings of its newly
acquired strip property to the Nevada
Gaming Control Board marking another
step towards its scheduled opening which
is going to be in just a couple of years
Sasha Loftus joins us now live from
right near the Mirage Sasha
Denise and Brian we've been waiting for
quite a while to see what the Hard Rock
Hotel will look like on the Las Vegas
Strip now some we spoke with tonight are
excited for the Futures while other say
they are a little sad to see the Mirage
go
I think it will be great after months of
anticipation we're finally getting our
first glimpse of a new era on the Las
Vegas Strip it's like really beautiful
the guitar bringing the lights and
everything on Wednesday Hard Rock
International presented its plan to the
Nevada Gaming Control Board to turn the
Mirage into this but the Mirage will be
in good hands as it becomes part of hard
rocks already amazing portfolio of
gaming it comes a year after MGM Resorts
announced its 1 billion dollar sale of
the property the rebrandt including a
guitar-shaped hotel similar to other
locations in the U.S replacing the
Mirage Volcano with 3 600 rooms at about
174 thousand square feet of Casino space
pools Villas and private gaming rooms
will also get a makeover the animal
habitats also will be gone it is Our
intention to build in All Suites guitar
shaped building very similar to what we
did in South Florida those in charge say
it's a great opportunity while many
tourists tell us they're still sad to
lose this well-known
you know notable and memorable and
others say they're willing to ride with
our City's ever-changing Skyline because
you can hold on to the past or you can
agree to move on to the Future
[Music]
now that the gaming control board
approved the hardbox licensing it will
go to the Nevada gaming commission for
regulatory approval on December 22nd and
the hotel itself is set to open sometime
in 2025. reporting live tonight Sasha
Loftus 8 News Now